[Music]
good morning everybody my name is
devadip today and I am a researcher in
Microsoft Research AI in Redmond and
today I am going to talk to you about
how to do meta reasoning in software
pipelines especially in big large
software pipelines mark Anderson's in
2011 said like software is eating the
world and indeed we are a giant company
with lots of software pipelines
everywhere but even today when we write
software pipelines there don't usually
react we write them nominally so they
don't react or reflect upon how the
resources are changing and how latency
and resource constraints may be changing
upon them dynamically and and change
parameters and configurations as well as
like you know where certain modules of
the pipelines are running so that they
can respect as best as they can
latencies and accuracy requirements that
this application at the end requires and
I will show you like how we are taking
steps to really achieve such
self-reflecting meta reasoning pipelines
and before we go to go on to that part
of the meta reasoning process I would
like to introduce the platform for
situated intelligence and which is a
framework that we have built here with a
large team of developers and researchers
in Microsoft Research in order to do
integrate integrative systems very
rapidly at the production level without
requiring a lot of like reinventing of
the wheel with terms of like
message-passing interprocess
communication distribution and
marshalling and de marshalling of like
you know different data types and
messages so let me introduce to you the
platform for situated intelligence and
what is SCI so it's completely
open-source framework which allows you
to enable the fast development and
fielding and study of integrative AI
systems like robots home robots
autonomous cars drones and you can
quickly write all such modules using the
SCI framework and at it's very like you
knows at the risk of oversimplifying SCI
will take in like you know inputs from
cameras microphone arrays or any other
sensor that you have and we have a large
array of pre-built components that we
call inside
which are already designed to take in
inputs from almost any camera USB camera
web camera Kinect lidar and make it
available as in a publish/subscribe
system within the SCI framework and then
you can have like you know write all
your modules like face tracking sound
localization speeds source
identification and then higher-level
constructs like let's say you want to
send like you know signals to the motor
controllers of a robot or you want to
like you know talk to humans interacting
with the robot and this is all like you
know the concurrency the runtime the
parallelization is just all handled for
you so that if you as the robotic
systems developer don't have to do
really anything other than focus on
writing the core logic that you want to
write and we have an eco-lodge ecosystem
of AI components like sensor components
imaging audio speech and language vision
interaction as well as like bridges to
existing frameworks which have in the
open source world like OpenCV library as
and the robot operating system which is
popular in the open source world and SCI
is open sourced under the MIT license so
it's completely free for you to do
whatever you want with including
commercial applications and now would
like to talk a little bit about the
meta-reasoning
scenario so imagine you have a software
pipeline and in this case we have a very
basic like you know for purposes of
elucidation a basic of software pipeline
where you have an image stream going
into a phase detector with the phase
detector has an option of four
algorithms some algorithms are very
cheap and fast but inaccurate but some
algorithms may be a big giant neural
network which are very accurate but take
more time and then the output of this
phase detector is a stream of faces and
the stream of faces goes to a like for
example a face landmark detector whose
job again is it has this like you know
various algorithms of one of these may
be very fast and give you only five
landmarks on your face but as algorithm
3 may be very expensive and give you 87
landmarks on the face and then the
output of this is a sequence of like you
know a stream of faces face locations
and landmarks on their faces and you can
imagine that like you know that the
system level designer wants that no
matter what kind of image stream comes
in
or no matter on what computer or system
you are running it's very important to
never exceed 450 milliseconds and let's
say we want to make it such that not
utilizing the 450 millisecond budget
efficiently it results in a penalty like
we don't we want to penalize that but
anytime you exceed 450 milliseconds you
must pay a large penalty as well and
that's really bad so we want this the
last function the overall utility
function looks somewhat like this
u-shaped curve where it slopes down
gently up to 0 around 450 and then goes
up rapidly back up again and what you
would really want to do is that we are
that no matter what image comes in you
want to switch algorithms such that this
latency is held constant both at the
phase detector and the phase landmark
part so we we pose this as a structured
bandit problem which is just machine
learning terminology which basically
says that we can look at partial
feedback of this only or this loss
function scalar loss function coming in
at the end of the pipeline and learn
from it using the context from resonate
50 features and this contextual bandit
algorithm will learn how to do
meta-reasoning
and depending upon what images is coming
in it will learn to switch the algorithm
such that the latency is is respected
and you can see how this can be very
important in scenarios where you are
using such pipelines in either embedded
inside a robot or in as a service on the
web as for example like in Microsoft
cognitive services we're respecting
latencies and use up of and user
guarantees performance guarantees is
very important and sometimes maybe even
contractual so let me give you like an
example of how this is going to work so
in this example we will only have the
phase detector pipeline and which has
got four different algorithms going from
like very small inaccurate but very fast
models to very extremely expensive
models but which are much more accurate
so in this you can see for example this
is a plot of the utility stream which is
the lost stream at the end and and the
higher is the number that means the
utility you want that is bad and you
want this number to go down as much as
quickly as possible so and then here you
are seeing like the algorithm choice
that the meta reasoner is making so
right now the meta reasoner is deciding
that using algorithm three is the best
possible thing which minimizes the loss
the best because of the content of the
image and for how much time it is taking
it's coming close to 450 milliseconds so
it really wants to stay around use
parameter 3 once in a while it's going
to do some exploration for example it
dipped to and used algorithm 2 here
again it used algorithm 2 algorithm 1 it
continuously does in in our case the
parameter is set to be like to do 10%
exploration 10% of the time such that
like you know we can react to
non-stationarity is like if the
distribution is changing unless you
explore you are not going to detect that
the circumstances are changing and your
reward function is actually changing but
now I'm going to what I'm going to do is
going to intro I'm going to simulate you
introducing a large number of people by
putting this picture in front of the web
camera which is which is on my laptop
and we will see that like you know
usually the phase detector is designed
currently in such a way that it's an SDK
that we are using that the larger the
number of like interfaces that are
present in the image the slower every
algorithm runs and this is something we
have benchmarked against standard
datasets so I'm going to simulate here
like you know and you are seeing here
how it is at 3 most of the time pay
attention to this as I introduced this
and you will see this show up here in
the screen that it will immediately
change regime and go down to around
algorithm 0 because all the algorithms
will take much larger time an algorithm
0 will then start taking around 450
millisecond and and the metal on a
recognizer will will see that and will
will automatically adjust so
so now you can suddenly see that it's no
longer like in your tracking algorithm 3
but it switches down to like you know
other algorithm choice 0 and that really
like you know minimizes the late
minimizes the number of seconds it will
take in terms of utility and then as I
quickly remove it it will go back up and
as you can see it it immediately went
back up and is now again tracking
algorithm 3 these dips once in a while
are again it the algorithm is exploring
the meta reasoner is exploring to make
sure that it's the regime has not
changed and the compute resources and
the number of phases are still ok and
and this is a quick thirty example of
how a meta reasoning can really help us
optimize software pipelines end to end
such that like you know the key
performance indicators are respected no
matter what distribution of an input and
state and resource constraints are
available thank you very much and we
hope to talk to you more
[Music]
you